힌두교에 따르면 두 가지 삶의 철학이 있는데
노 브라블럼
발음 딱이야
노 브라블럼이 뭐냐면
이건 이 정도 문제도 아니야
다 문제도 이렇게 넘어가려는 거 하나
두 번째로는 뭐냐면
힌두교 안에서는요
지금 벌어진 일들이 갑자기 내가 운이 나빠서 벌어진 게 아니고요
내 운명의 수레바퀴 속에서
그 톱니바퀴 속에서
수천 년, 수만 년 전부터 이미 이게 계획된 거예요
그래서 이게 나한테 분류해서
화를 내거나 분노해도 그건 바뀌지 않은 거예요
내가 눌리는 것도 10만 년 전부터 계획이 되어 있었어
우리의 비밀이 물리기로 결정이 돼 있었어
우리 NH증권, NH투자증권의 백찬규 위원님 나오셨습니다
사실 저희 머니코믹스 보시는 분들은
아침 방송에 목요일에 천재오빠라는 별명으로
또 출연을 하고 계신데
천재오빠요?
왜냐하면 모르는 게 없으시고
반응이 일단 너무 좋으세요
그래서 제가 사실 저녁 방송까지 모시게 된 건데
리서치센터 생활을 오래 하셨잖아요
그러면 어떻게...
어떤 거 커버하셨어요?
투자전략이라는 거를 담당을 했고요
그러니까 탑다운 분석
그러니까 시장의 전체적인 방향성
그다음에 그 방향성 중에서 어떤 국가가 좋은지
또 상반기는 한국을 한다면
하반기는 또 어느 국가를 할지
이런 것들을 관장했었습니다
알겠습니다
그럼 오늘 해주실 주제가 어떤 거죠?
제가 사실 너무 궁금해서
개인적으로 이것 좀 해달라고
간곡하게 또 요청을 드렸습니다
인도와 베트남, 신흥국 시장
어떻게 투자하면 좋을지
진짜 한참 뜨거웠다고 듣나요?
그다음에 어떻게 하는지?
기억이 없는데 어떻게 되고 있습니까?
일단은 인도 주식시장이에요
2024년까지 봤을 때 한 10년을 보면
무려 미국보다 수익률이 괜찮았었습니다
S&P500보다 Nifty Fifty가 훨씬 더 괜찮았었어요
그런데 트럼프가 작년에 40% 관세
품목별로 또 50% 관세를 매기다 보니까
그때부터 주가가 좀 쉬어가면서
인도 한 박자 쉬었다
그다음에 베트남 같은 경우에
제가 영어 발음 좀 이상하게 하면
이렇게 댓글을...
많이 달려서 반성하고 있습니다
제가 P.E.R이라고 하겠고요
R.O.E라고 잘 발음을 하겠습니다
왜냐면 외국 출신이에요
제가 이제 뭐 P.E.R 아니면
어로이 같은 경우
아니면 비엔남 뭐 이런 얘기를 하니까
인도에 오래 계셨죠?
아 저는 부모님이 인도 사세요
지금이요?
네 30년 넘게 인도 사시고
인도도 뉴델리나 이런 데 아니고
저 북쪽에 히말라야 산맥에 살고 계십니다
대박
그래서 참고로 제가 본가를 가려면요
비행기 타고 뭐 가는데 하루 다 날라가고요
그리고 거기서 버스 타고 17시간을 가야 됩니다
와
그래서 웬만해서 못 갑니다
와 아니 근데 개인적으로 궁금한 게 너무 많아요
아니 그러면 결혼하실 때도 뭐 상견례도 뭐 인도에서 한다든지
네 저는 했습니다
인도식으로 하셨나요?
아닙니다 저는 한국에...
코끼리 타고?
아닙니다
아 인도는요 코끼리 있는데 코끼리 잠깐 얘기 드리면요
한국에서 불을 자랑하려면 결혼 어디서 하죠?
호텔에서?
신라호텔?
신라호텔 영빈관에서 하거나 호텔에서 하죠
인도는요 불을 과시하기 위해서 어떤 걸 하는지 아세요?
코끼리 타요?
코끼리가 등장하면 그 집 잘 사는 거예요
진짜 했어
코끼리가 3마리 나온다 대부호인 거예요
대부호입니까 대부호?
근데 약간 못 산다 그러면 이제 말 등장합니다
말 타고 등장하고요
집에서 코끼리 키우는 거 갖고 온 거예요?
호수죠 호수죠
아 이거 주식 얘기하려다가 자꾸 딴 얘기 하려고 했는데
뭐가 있었냐면요 예전에 델리데이 경영학과에
한국 분이 다니신 거예요?
네 한국 분이 다니신 거예요?
네 한국 분이 다니신 적이 있으세요
그러다가 이제 그 안에서 왕족 분하고 결혼을 하신 분이 계세요
근데 이제 계급이 뭔지 아세요?
이따가 제가 계급 이야기 드릴 텐데
브라만 아래가 뭐였죠?
브라만, 크샤트레야, 그 다음 이제 평민 입구 제일 밑에 수드라가 있는
수드라
뭘까요 우리는?
우린 수드라요
힌두교를 안 믿었으니까 업보가 너무 많이 쌓여 있는 거예요
그래서 우리는 인간의 형상을 하고 태어났지만
까르마 업보가 많이 쌓여 있는 거예요
그런데 어떻게 되죠?
왕족하고 천민이 결혼한 거예요?
아무리 한국인이더라도 그럼 이분의 계급이 떨어집니다
그래서 막 신문에도 나오고 막 이랬었어요
그런데 그런데 이제 그 집에 딱 놀러 갔더니 재충격이 있습니다
일단 입구에 이렇게 왕궁 같은 게 있어요
아 이건 뭘까?
문도 없고 한 3층 높이가 있었거든요
이게 뭐지 딱 봤더니 그 안에 코끼리가 삽니다
네?
코끼리 집이 3개가 있는 거예요
왜냐면 그래도 아버지께서 사랑한 딸이 가니까
이제 선물로 그걸 해준 거예요
인도 분은 딸이었어요?
네 네
여자분이셨어
문제가 뭐죠?
코끼리를...
코끼리를 키우려면 어마어마한 비용이 듭니다
그런데 그걸 3마리나 키운다?
어마어마한 부를 자랑하는 겁니다
혹시 그러면 돈이 좀 없으면 인도에 물소가 많던데
아 소는 감히 거기에 쓰질 못해요
아 물소는 또 모시고 오시면 안 됩니까?
소가 뭐죠?
소가 힌두교에서 가장 신성시되는 거야
특히 흰소 뭐냐면요
그 업보가 없어지고 까르마가 없어지는 그 끝의 단계에는
흰소로 이게 이제 발현이 됩니다
감히 소에게
아 모시고 올 수 없는 겁니까?
감히 어떻게 끌고 오고 모시고
길거리에 누워 있어도요 사람들이 비키라고 못합니다
어찌 감히
아 차가 뒤에 1키로가 2키로가 밀려 있어도 그건 안 됩니다
대박
아니 그럼 불경술한 얘기를 하신다니까
아니 이래서 소들 하나 맞는 거 아니야?
모시고 와서 영호를 좀 드려보니까 궁금해
아니 지금 생물 유튜버도 하셔도 되겠고
뭐 오늘 준비해온 얘기는 조금 이따 하고
일단 인도 음식이라도 좀 안 돼
제가 궁금한 게 인도 가서 잘못 먹으면 그렇게 배 아프다
이런 얘기들 많으니까
실제 어떻습니까?
저는 만약에 슈카님하고 저희 출장 갈 수도 있잖아요
만약에 출장을 가게 된다면은
제가 슈카님께 일단 말리고 싶은 게 두 가지 있거든요
저희는 물론 좋은 호텔을 가겠지만
뭘 해야 되죠?
샐러드 드시는 걸 막을 거예요
왜요 왜요?
왜냐면 한국 사람들 호텔 호캉스 가서 아침에 뭐 드시죠?
일단 샐러드 한 접시 가져옵니다
거기서는 안 돼요
6성급 호텔 5성급 호텔도 여러분 인도 출장 가시면 샐러드 안 됩니다
왜요 왜요?
샌드위치에 들어갔던 그 야채들 안 됩니다 왜죠?
왜요?
익히지 않았기 때문에
원래 안 익히잖아요
자 거기에 과연 비료를 뭘로 쓸까요?
옛날 휴먼 리소스를 넣나요?
네 휴먼 리소스를 넣어서
예전의 방식으로 하는데 그게 문제가 뭐가 있다?
여러 기생충들의 문제가 있습니다
여러분 그걸 잘못 드시면요 어떻게 된다?
한국에서는 단 한 번도 경험해 보지 못한 배탈이 나오는데요
뱃속에 울버린이 들어가서
이게 창을 창 꺼서 벽을 막 긁어요
그래서 갑갑 이렇게 찌릅니다
그 고통이 굉장히 오래 갑니다
두 번째 드시면 안 되는 거 뭘까요?
제가 이번에 인도 출장 가서 제가 보고서를 한 번 썼었는데
제가 인도 출장 가서 굉장히 깜짝 놀란 게 있어요
그 나라 인당 GDP 2,500불밖에 안 되는데
그 나라에 스타벅스가 굉장히 많아진 거예요
스타벅스가 많아져서 더우니까 너무 더우니까 가서
아 한 잔 딱 하고 싶은데 제가 마셨을까요 안 마셨을까요?
저 겨울에도 알을 마십니다
가서 당연히 따뜻한 아메리카노 마셨습니다
왜 그럴까요?
자 그 얼음이요 어느 물로 흘렸을까요?
겐지스 알에서 나왔나요?
현미경으로 확대해보면 무슨 알인지 모른다?
어디서 하는지 모르는데 그걸 잘못 마시는 순간 어떻게 된다?
지옥을 맛봅니다
아마 인도 갔다 오신 분들 아마 아실 겁니다
약은 한국 약이 듣는다 안 듣는다? 듣지 않아요
약은 무조건 현지 약을 드셔야 돼요
그러면은 야 인도에 이런 약 먹어도 돼?
라고 의심과 걱정을 많이 하시는데
거기 계신 수많은 엘지와 삼성과 현대차의 임직원분들이요
이미 다 수십 년간 임상실험을 거쳐서 판정이 됐기 때문에
저도 가면은 현지 약 사 먹습니다
거기 복지약 수준 되게 높아요
아니 지금 사실 아까 주식 얘기할 때보다 종접자 같다 오늘은
그러니까 주식 얘기는 진짜요?
인도는 지금
주식 얘기는 됐고
예전에는 얼마 전에 제가 인도 봤을 때 인도에
왜?
무한으로 그냥 나오네?
하하하하하하
왜냐면 우리 슈가님이 또 호기심 천국이다 보니까
이때 이때 다 털어놨다
인도 서쪽에 무슨 커다란 고속도로 두 개 도시를 연결해서
뭐 엄청난 발전을 이루고 있다 이런
여러분 투자할 때 이 나라의 국력이 얼마나 올라왔다는 뭘로 평가하시죠?
여러분 제일 중요한 게요 도로의 질이에요
무슨 얘기냐면요
그 나라에 국력이 있고 국격이 생기면요
인프라가 발전이 되고요 그럼 도로가 매끈해져요
왜? 좋은 콘크리트와 좋은 아스팔트를 쓰니까
좋은 시멘트를 쓰니까
이번에 갔더니 너무 매끈하고요
정말 부드럽게 변했어요
예전에는 움푹 파인 거 나오고 막 땜질 돼있고
어디는 흙 나오고 막 울퉁불퉁하고 난리도 아니었었거든요
포장이 이렇게
이제 가시면요
최소한 뉴델리 정도에서 고속도로 타고 호텔 가실 때는요
택시 안에서 매끈한 도로를 기대하실 수가 있어요
제가 지금 자료 한번 띄워주시면 자료 보면서 같이 이야기 한 번
질문이 또 있거든
네 좋아요
질문 나중에 끝나가지고
인도는 일단 3대 그룹이 인도에 진출을 했거든요
우리의 투자자금도 가야 되느냐 말아야 되느냐가 좀 고민인 시점이에요
그런데 지금은 트럼프 때문에 한번 길이 막혔다라는 거고요
제가 또 이야기를 드려보겠습니다
일단은 인도의 계급제를 한번 먼저 말씀드릴게요
여기서 보시면 인도는 지배층이 옛날엔 브라만이 있었고 크샤트리아
그다음에 평민인 바이샤와 수두라가 있었고요
그리고 그 밑에 뭐가 있죠? 달리트라고 불가척천민 불가시천민이 있습니다
근데 사실 이 왼쪽의 계급도는요
사실 0%예요
영국이 고착화시킨 거예요
사실은 인도는 이런 식으로 구분을 안 해요
인도는 뭘로 한다? 더 복잡합니다
아 더 복잡하다
왜냐면 3000개를 구분했는데요
이걸 라띠라고 하거든요
이 라띠 같은 경우에는 또 뭐냐면요
이름과 성에 그 직업과 계급이 단호가 들어있어요
그래서 인도 사람 만나잖아요
그럼 슈카님 보더라도 먼저 인사가 뭔지 아세요?
조금 나이 든 분은 아버님 존함이 어떻게 되십니까? 먼저 물어봐요
그게 궁금해서 물어볼 거야? 아니에요
상대방의 계급과 직업을 평가하려고 물어봐요
끝입니다
그렇게 되면 이제 외국인이네 이렇게 되죠
다음 페이지도 같이 한번 볼까요?
이게 재밌는 게요
인도라는 나라가 단일국가 같지만 연합국가입니다
전 인도 아대륙이 통일된 적이 없었어요
최초로 된 게 영국이 만든 겁니다
그럼 그전까지 뭐가 있었냐
지역 왕들이 있었어요
뭐냐면 한 주가 한국보다 더 크고 한국보다 인구가 더 많습니다
그런데 거기에 왕들이 계세요
왕들이 계시고요
지금도 계세요?
지금도 계시죠
이 뒤에 성 같은 데 있잖아요
이 성이 이분이 왕이 사시는 거예요 왕이
저기 뭐 주지사도 있고 할 텐데
그러니까 중앙정부의 권력이 분명히 센 부분이 있고요
지방정부 특히 지방정부에서도 행정부 개념이 아니고
지방왕의 권한이 굉장히 센 데가 많아요
그래서 아마슈카님은 기억나실 거예요
왜 한참 포스코 일관자철소 만들고
그때 인도 진출을 한다고 막 발표했었거든요
파이넥스 공법으로 막 한다고 했을 때
그때가 2007년 8년이었잖아요
그때가 인도에 진출한다고 했었는데
착공이 무산이 됩니다
왜 그랬을까요?
지금 돌아가신 그 전 왕께서 이러셨대요
나의 아름다운 해안에 저렇게 불성사하는 걸 질 수가 없대요
그래서 이게 무산이 되고
중앙정부하고 삼심가고 다 해서 포스코가 이겼는데도 불구하고
결국엔 거기서 손을 떼고 나왔습니다
근데 그게 한국만이냐?
월마트도 그런 적도 있고요
그래서 이게 점점점점 줄고는 있지만
한국과는 다른 프로세스가 작동을 해요
근데 우리가 인도라는 거 어떻게 생각하시죠?
인도라는 거 보통은
와 이거 강한 자만이 살아남고 지저분하고
이게 괜찮은가 막 겐지스강 이런 얘기를 하는데
사실은 인도가 미국을 점령했다라는 표현도 저는 쓰거든요
뭐냐면요
미국 기업의 웬만한 상장 기업의 CEO, CTO, CIO
그러니까 C레벨들 있잖아요
다 인도계예요
특히 미국 시총 2, 3위 구글, 마이크로소프트, 수장 인도계잖아요
너무 신기해요 이게
그리고 인도 IIT라고 인도공대가요
MIT보다 입결이 높다고 해요
왜냐면 MIT 장학금을 타고 온 사람을 인터뷰했는데 인도계였어요
여기 왜 오셨어요? 했더니
아 인도공과대학 떨어져서 MIT에 왔습니다
이게 되게 유명한 인터뷰잖아요
근데 그런 분들이 와서 CEO들을 다 하고 있어요
IT뿐만이 아니고 산업재나 소비재 쪽에서도 하고 있고요
특히 CTO나 CIO 같은 그러니까
Investment나 아니면 Technology 쪽은 이쪽이 장학했다
근데 정말 희한한 게요
한국 사람들은 가서 2세, 3세 낫고 좋은 대학 나오면서 가도 매니저급이거든요
근데 얘네들은 인도에서 태어났는데
지금은 Citizen이 돼서 C레벨들을 다 하고 있습니다
이게 인도인들의 굉장히 좀 무서움이다라고 좀 보고 있어요
저분들도 개그? 그런 거 따집니까?
아니요 미국 나오신 분들은 안 해요
그래서 이게 바로 신분 상승의 사다리인 거예요
이거 해서 좋은 IT 기업 가서 잘 돼서 미국에 가서 미국에서 가족들 다 데리고 오는 게
그래서 여기가 의사나 건축가보다 IT를 더 선호하는 게
이런 신분계층의 사다리가 유럽이나 미국에 열려 있고요
전 세계 프로그래머 1위들은 다 인도 출신이시잖아요
진짜 어떻게 그렇게 되는 거지?
그래서 인도에 대해서 알아야 될 거고
그럼 인도가 어떻게 발전했느냐가 중요한데
여러분 여기는 좀 관심 있게 한번 들어보세요
이제 제가 착안한 내용인데요
첫 번째는 뭐냐면
중국 쪽은 산업자본주의가 발전을 할 때 가장 성장한 국가가 중국입니다
무슨 얘기냐면요
1970년대 80년대까지는 양진영 간의 이념의 대결이 있었고요
90년대부터 이념의 대결이 없어지고
이제 본격적인 산업자본주의와 캐피털리즘이 펼쳐지기 시작했는데
그때 뭐가 있었다?
전 세계 공장 재화는 중국이 생산을 해요
그리고 디자인과 소비는 미국을 비롯한 선진국이 합니다
세계의 글로벌 공장과 소비처가 돌아가던 양식이에요
그런데 어떻게 됐죠?
2008년이 지나면서 산업자본주의라는 게 망가지기 시작하고요
디지털 자본주의라는 게 들어옵니다
리얼 굿즈는 중국이 했는데요
디지털 굿즈는 인도가 만들기 시작한 거예요
코딩하죠, 생산해내죠, IT 하청 다 하죠
그런 일이 있다 보니까
이쪽 부근에서는 미국 거를 생산해주는 생산 공장이 된 겁니다
그러면서 인도가 굉장히 빠르게 성장했는데
이거는 두 개가 있더라고요
이 두 개가 뭐냐면
일단 인도는 공용어로 영어를 썼다는 점
영어를 썼다는 점
그 대단한 IT 기업들이 1990년대, 2000년대 초반에는
그냥 디지털 센터, 콜센터 역할을 했었어요
피자 전화하면 여기서 전화 받고
AS 요청하면 여기서 전화 받고
그 영어가 기반이 됐고요
그리고 이네들이 똑똑하고 셈이 빠르다 보니까
그런 콜센터가 디지털 하청으로 전환하기 시작합니다
아니 근데 저는 인도 성장하는 거 보면서 궁금한 게
잘하는 사람들이 다 미국으로 가버리잖아요
그러면 인도의 어떤 경제라든지 IT가 성장을 그만큼 할 수 있어요?
아 그러기에는 사람이 너무 많아요
제가 인구 많은 나라도 살아보고 다녀보기도 하면서 느낀 거는 뭐냐면
인구가 많을 때는 정부나 정책과 사회 문화가
철저한 생명 경시 문화가 있습니다
아 생명 경시 문화
인구가 철저하게 생명 존중이 되는 문화가 있거든요
아 경시 문화가?
아니 뉴스 보시면 나오잖아요
무슨 홍수나면 몇백 명 죽었대요
그러고 또
끝이에요
기차역에서 뭐 앞서 몇 십 명
그 티도 안 나요
저는 너무 충격이거든요
티도 안 나요
거기는 진짜 너무 많아요
그래서 이런 게 참 인도의 좀 다른 점이지 않나
뭐 이런 얘기를 하고 있습니다
인도 가끔 뭐 보면은
다큐멘터리 같은 거 보면
기차에 올라타 갖고 가시는 분들 있잖아요
요즘은 이제 그런 건 거의 없어졌다라고 보는
아 제가 예전에는요
기차가 이제 빠른 거 느린 거 뭐 여러 가지가 있을 거잖아요
그럼 느린 거는 계속 밀려요
심지어 정말 많이 밀릴 때는요
한 1박 2일 밀릴 때도 있고요
16시간 밀릴 때도 있어요
그래서 여기서 다 자요
1박 2일 밀리면 무슨 보상금 이런 거
아 인도잖아요
왜 그러세요
생명도 경시하는 밤에
니 표를 경시 안 하겠니
근데 이게 또 문화가 다른 게요
힌두교는 어떤 문화가 있다
내가 너무 힘들고 이런 당황스러운 일이 있어도
힌두교에 따르면 두 가지 삶의 철학이 있는데
노 브라블럼 발음 딱이네요
노 브라블럼 딱이래요
노 브라블럼이 뭐냐면은
어 이건 이런 이 정도 문제도 아니야
다 문제야
두 번째로는 뭐냐면은
힌두교 안에서는요
지금 벌어진 일들이 갑자기 내가 운이 나빠서 벌어진 게 아니고요
내 운명의 수레바퀴 속에서 그 톱니바퀴 속에서
수천 년 수만 년 전부터 이미 이게 계획된 거예요
그래서 이게 나한테 분류해서 화를 내거나 분노해도
그건 바뀌지 않은 거예요
와 그러면 내 기차가 1박 2일 밀린 게 수십만 년 전부터 계획된 거예요
이미 예정돼 있던 거예요 내 삶에
운명의 수레바퀴는 돌아가고 있다
운명의 수레바퀴입니다
운명의 수레바퀴
네 기차는 12시간 뒤에 오는 거야
내가 눌리는 것도 10만 년 전부터 계획이 되어 있었어
우리의 주식도 10만 년
이미 물리기로 결정이 돼 있었어
지금 화면 한번 보시면 지금 왼쪽에 보시면 뭐
인포시스나 위프로나 뭐 이런 기업들이 있는데
현재 대단한 IT 기업들이거든요
얼마나 대단하냐면 미국에도 다 이렇게 뭐
DR 개념, 예탁증서 개념으로 상장까지 돼 있고요
이렇게 될 수 있던 배경은 오른쪽 보시면
서비스 부문 수출에서 73%가
관련된 수출이에요
그러니까 여기는 중국하고 다른 게
중국은 물건을 만들어서 수출을 하는데
여기는 재화보다는 이런 디지털 굿즈의 수출이
상당히 좀 많다라고 생각을 하고 있습니다
그러니까 신흥국은 늘 그래요
뭐냐면요 신흥국은 전 세계 자본주의에 기여하는 게 뭐죠
자본주의에 기여할 수 있는 방안이 코스트 리덕션이에요
한국도 했었잖아요 80년대 90년대
정말 근면성실하게 밤 안 자고 월급 적게 받으면서
그걸로 비용을 낮추고 마진을 키우면서
전 세계에서
전 세계 경제를 부양을 했었고요
그다음에 어디가 있죠 중국에 있잖아요
싼 임금으로 싸게 공급하면서 했죠
그다음에 어디죠
비엔남이었잖아요
비엔남이 그렇게 전 세계 공급하고
그다음에 어디죠
지금 이제 인디아가 그걸 노리고 있어요
이제까지는 서비스 부분만 했는데
오케이 중국하고 싸운다
그 자리 내가 꿰차겠다
그러면 이 대단한 인구를 데려다 놓고
우리가 이제는 제조까지 가겠다라고 하는 게
지금의 모디 총리의 계획이고요
그게 잘 되냐
쉽지만은 않지만
지금 오른쪽에 보시는 것처럼
우리가 보기에도 대단한 공장들
글로벌 컴퍼니들의 반도체 공장하고 있고요
인도 시장 조금 계열을 보면은
신흥국가 있잖아요
여기서 보시면 EM이라는 신흥국가에서
그러니까 중국, 인도, 대만, 한국이요
4대 천왕입니다 신흥국에서
대단한 나라예요
한 10년 전, 15년 전만 해도
한국의 절반밖에 안 됐거든요
어느새 이렇게 따라왔습니다
근데 오른쪽이 재밌죠
오른쪽을 보면은
신흥국 시장의 전형적인 특징이에요
금융 업종이 높다
왜죠?
한국도 옛날에 높았어요
식당을 만들 때
금융 관련 회사부터
특히 은행부터 상장을 시킵니다
왜? 안정적이고
대부분 국가가 갖고 있던 거를
민영화시키고 그걸 상장하기 때문에
신흥국은 금융 업종이 다 높아요
그런데 재밌는 거
화면 한 번 더 보실까요?
오른쪽 차트 보면
여기 IT 있죠?
IT가 20%예요
금융 IT 합치면 50%
신흥국에서요
IT 20% 되는 나라 있을까요?
없습니다
대부분이 다 제조업 기반
인력 기반으로 만들잖아요
그래서 인도가
어쨌든 시장의 주목을 받을 수 있던 거는
이 업종에 대한 수혜가 굉장히 크다였고요
반면에 이런 소비재나 경기 소비재
혹은 유틸리티 같은 경우
커뮤니케이션이 보통 통신사 아니면
전력 회사들의 비중이 신흥국에선 큰데
그건 상당히 적습니다
그래서 이 나라는 다른 신흥국하고
조금 다른 관점이다라고 보고 있습니다
아니 그래서 사실 궁금한 부분이
인도 증시 그 뭐라 그래
리프티?
리프티!
네, 그게 리프티!
코스피 200 이런 지수입니다
아니 사실 이제
리프티, 피프티 아니고요
리프티, 피프티
아니 미국도 투자하기 좀 힘들고
북장도 잘 모르겠고
인도나 중국 뭐 이런 것 좀 생각 좀 해봤거든요
신흥국에 돈이 들어올 때는 몇 가지 전제 조건이 필요해요
빠르게 한번 같이 이야기 해볼까요?
왼쪽 차트 이거 보시면
전 세계 주식시장을 MSCI 액휘라고 합니다
이 액휘가 뭐냐면 여기 보이시죠?
ACWI를 저희는 액휘라고 하는데
All Country World Index라는 지수입니다.
그래서 선진국이 90%고요
신흥국이 10% 정도 차지합니다
전 세계에서 한국, 중국, 인도, 대만이 아무리 크다고 하더라도
10%밖에 안 돼요
그럼 딱 보면 인도는 전체에서는 또 2%밖에 안 됩니다
그럼 이쪽에 돈이 어떻게 들어와야 될까요?
자 한번 보실까요?
여기가 핵심입니다
전 세계 주식시장의 비중이 91 대 9로 돼 있습니다
근데 선진국이 먼저 보통 올라요
우리 그랬잖아요
2024년, 2025년에 미국이 먼저 갑니다, 그렇죠?
맞아요
자연스럽게 미국의 비중이 커지면서
DM이 95, 96을 넘어가기 시작해요
근데 문제가 뭐죠?
선진국이 너무 많은 거예요
그럼 자연스럽게 또 분산을 해줘야 되겠잖아요
그럼 이거에 는 거에 대해서 극단적으로
살을 만약에 다 간다?
얘는 밸류에이션도 비싸죠
이제 금리도 내릴 만큼 내렸어
유동성은 스피르보다 더 이상 미국에
아니 미국 지수 22배, 23배 주인데
야 나는 25배는 넘게 못 주겠어
그럼 돈이 어디로 가죠?
그동안 안 올랐던 EM으로 가게 되는 거죠
그럼 여기는 유지되네요
전체 올라간 부분이 4 정도가 오면 어떻게 되죠?
EM 안에서는요
근 50% 가까이 돈 들어오는 거예요
그게 언제였다?
그게 2026년 상반기였죠
이런 흐름이 2025년 하반기부터 들어왔다고요
아니 사실은 제가 목요일날 버디버디에서 얘기해 드린 게 뭐죠?
언제 들어왔어?
분모가 안정이 되면, 분모가 뭐죠?
국채금리, ERP 같은 것들이 안정이 되면
다시 한 번 이게 괜찮아진다는데
이게 흔들려 버리니까 돈이 들어오다 지금 좀 멈추긴 했습니다
그냥 놔뒀으면요
선진국 PER 올라갔고 신흥국 PER 조금 낮게 있었는데
이게 캐치업 하면서 어떻게 됐다?
그림에서 보여지는 돈들이 계속 들어오기 시작했었다
이런 게 중요한 거예요
그러면 신흥국을 투자할 때 어떻게 해야 되죠?
아 인도가 막 인구가 많고 미래가 막 될 거 같고
인당 GDP 2,500불인데 5,000불 갈 때까지는 할 거야
이렇게 하셔도 되는데
기본적으로 신흥국은요
이 등락폭이 큽니다
시점이 중요해요
그래서 이거는 나눠서 사시다가
이런 국면이 왔을 때 좀 많이 사시면
그때 수익이 많이 나요
그러면 지금의 오늘 베트남 이야기도 못하겠네요
괜찮습니다 다음 시간에 기다리기 때문에
또 오네요 또 오네요
1부 2부가 있기 때문에
우리 인도들은 다 안 했어요
근데 인도 화면 한 번 보실까요?
인도가 그동안 올랐던 게요
그 07년도부터 2022년까지
지수가 총 매출이 그냥 연간 11% 증가했고요
마진율이 20%에 EPS가 쭉 올라간 거 보세요
일단은 기본적으로 실적이 다 있었다 여기는
그리고 외국인의 관심도 계속 증가를 했던 게요
인도 주식 시장을 이렇게 보면요
프로모터라는 건 대주주 정도로 이해하시면 됩니다
근데 보통은 신흥국은 누가 많죠?
개인 투자자가 많잖아요
근데 여기는 개인 투자자가 10%가 안 돼요
외국인 기관, 외국인 대주주
그다음에 현지 뮤추얼 펀드가 대부분
그러니까 이 주주 구성 보시면요
굉장히 선진화되어 있다니까요
이 시장이 갈만했다라고 봐요
왜냐면 인도 주식 시장의 역사가 일천하지 않습니다
일단은 1800년대 후반에 영국의 지배 시절부터
주식 시장에 대한 개념이 있던 국가거든요?
국가기 때문에 이런 자산 시장의 업종 구성이나 실적
그다음에 주주도 이렇게 잘 나눠졌다라고 보고 있어서
저는 이 나라는 꾸준하게 관심을 가져가자
다만 지난 1년간 트럼프의 영향으로 좀 재미가 없었지만
나눠서 갑을 맞아
제가 인도에서 여기까지만 오늘 이야기 드릴게요
예전에 어떻게 보셨어요 인도는?
북인도는 잘 살고 남인도는 못 산다
이렇게 배우지 않으셨나요?
그렇죠 북인도는 침략을 해서 아리아인이 들어와서 얼굴이 좀 하얗고
남쪽은 이제 얼굴이 시꺼멓고 수두라가 많고
그런데요 지금은 동서로 갈렸어요
남인도 북인도는 예전 얘기예요
예전에는 남북으로 나뉘었는데 지금 어떻게 됐다?
동서로 갈라져 있어요
동그라미 침대가 지금 잘 나가는 도시입니다
여기는 저희 부모님 사는 데라고 표시했고요
델리가 여기인데 여기에서 버스 타고 이만큼 가는데
여기서 보면 2cm 되겠네요
17시간이요?
17시간 걸린다
자 여기가 뉴델리 여기가 구자라트 뭐죠?
상업의 도시이자 지금 모디 총리의 고향
문바이는 뭐죠? 금융의 도시
그다음에 하이드라바드는
새로운 기업들 스타트업들의 탄생지
벵갈루르도 여기가 실리콘밸리 라고 불리는 동네입니다
뭐죠? 다 어디 쪽에 모여 있죠?
동쪽일까요? 서쪽일까요?
서쪽에 있죠 왜 서쪽에 있을까요?
조금 더 미국과 유럽에 가까워요
조금 더 저쪽으로 수출하기가 편해요
그렇기 때문에 기본적으로 지금은 서쪽을 중심으로 한
중앙정부의 발전이나 정책이 잘 먹히고
이게 조금 달라지고 있다
그리고 니니님 슈카님 저 없이 혹시 인도를 가신다면?
옷을 의관을 좀 정지하고
가실 수 있겠어요?
왜냐면 지도 한 번 더 보여주시겠어요?
이쪽에 이제 아쌈은 좀 잘 사는데
여기 좀 못 사는 동네가 좀 있어요
여기 외모하고 저희 외모하고 좀 비슷해요
문제가 저희보다 조금 더 시커멓을 뿐이지
외형이 너무 동아시아 사람하고 비슷해요
그럼 뭐냐면은 못 사는 줄 알고 되게 막대해요
저 예전에 친구하고 배낭여행을 여기서 여행을 둘이 다니는데
제 친구를 엄청 무시하는 거예요
왜냐면 이제 그 나라 가니까 되게 히피처럼 입고 가는데
딱 봐도 그쪽 사람인 거 같은 거예요
그래서 한국분들이 여행을 가실 땐
좀 의상을 좀 깔끔하게 입고 가시면
좀 대접을 받으신다
다만 너무 좋게 입고 가시면
다른 면으로 대접받는다고
대상이 될 수가 있습니다
대접이 아니라 대상이
조심하셔야 됩니다
제가 혹시 다음에 또 기회가 닿는다면
이어서 인도 좀
오늘 기업은 하나도 얘기 못 하셨죠
아니 지금 오늘 시청자들 난리 났어요
인도는 지금 정규 편성을 해달라고
주식은 지금이 아니고 인도는 지금이니까
인도는 지금 인도는 지금
인도 그 얼음 갖고 와서 현미경으로 보는 콘텐츠 하면
백만조여씩 받을 거 같은데
저 자리에 인도 물이 있거든요
아직 안 마신 거 그거
아직 안 마신 거
인도 물 인도 물
저희 인도에 한 200ml짜리가 있는데
인도 아저씨가 되게 해맑게 울고 있는데
제 주변 직원들 주려고 했는데
아무도 안 마시는 게 지금 1년 넘게 제 자리예요
일상 실험
용도가 뭡니까
사람들이 마시는 거죠 당연히
힘든 거예요 마시는 거예요
마시는 겁니다 생수예요
다만 한 3일 동안 못 보실 수가 있습니다
자 알겠습니다
자 오늘 준비한 인도 기업 얘기
하나도 못했고요
다음 시간에 우리 위원님 다시 한 번 모시고
인도 입문하다가 끝났는데
다음에 인도 기업 얘기까지
한번 듣는 시간 마련해 보도록 하겠습니다
아유 위원님 감사합니다
감사합니다
자 오늘은 여기까지 하겠습니다
여러분 감사합니다
감사합니다 안녕